ça serait partie de ce coin là ça aurait
traversé la route et puis après avec le
vent pousse à embaucher les gens
jusqu'au villa bernard vallet n'a rien
pu faire pour épargner ses terres en
l'espace de deux heures
l'incendié qui s'est déclaré ce dimanche
à méré a réduit en cendres 60 hectares
de chaume les attracteurs une charrue et
puis j'ai essayé de couper devant mais
il yal'affaire quoi ça saute et les
raids labour et les bombes y est déjà là
quand tu avec la charrue parce que entre
le moment que je l' ai vu que j'aille
attelé je revienne savez effet déjà
peut-être à km ou deux une trentaine de
sapeurs pompiers du département et dix
véhicules spécialisés ont été mobilisés
pour circonscrire les flammes
un incendie dont l'origine reste
inconnue l'imprudence est en général la
cause principale
c'est pas une vue de l'esprit le mégot
jeté par là par la fenêtre un quand le
feu il part sur la banquette le long de
la route c'est bien quelqu'un a jeté un
mégot fort probablement ça peut être des
feux allumés un type feu de camp qui
barbecue c'est c'est pas une légende on
l'a on a eu un départ de feu hier lié
lié à cela
donc vraiment c'est un appel à la
vigilance de chacun de chaque citoyen en
cette période de sécheresse pour éviter
de mettre le feu parce que bon quand
c'est de la chaume qui brûle c'est pas
c'est pas bien grave mais à partir du
moment où ça commence à menacer des
sous-bois des habitations skis et ski ce
qui peut être le cas
bon c'est quand même un petit peu plus
fâchés depuis le début du mois de juin
les pompiers de l'yonne sont intervenus
à 200 reprises pour circonscrire des
feux de chaume